appui aux étudiants quelles sont les
solutions que vous vous proposez pour
permettre à ces étudiants de ne pas
devoir subir une hausse des fr de
scolarité je pense que dans un premier
temps on aurait d avoir un véritable
échange un véritable forum démocratique
pour parler de l'avenir de nos
universités ça nous aurait permis
d'établir assez clairement qu'avant de
parler de problème de sous-financement
faud regarder le mal fininancement
comment finalement nos
universités détourne des sommes qui
devent être consacré à la formation et
l'envoie dans l'immobilisation l' voit
dans la recherche appliquée pour la
grande entreprise pour les grandes
transnationales et jusqu'à un certain
point c'est c'est nos universités sont
son sont sous influence et avec des
sommes dont profit je veux
dire les entreprises et on demande aux
étudiants maintenant de payer la note
fait qu'il y a déjà une première étape
si on on calibrait ça comme dans le
reste du pays déjà on réduirait
pablement la facture aux étudiantes aux
étudiants ensuite si il y a fort
probablement quelques bonifications
amélioration de de de procédés puis de
processus qui peuvent être apportés dans
une université et si on a encore du
financement il existe des des des dira
des stratégies pas très onéreuses je
regarde par rapport à l'Alliance sociale
ce qu'on a mis de l'avant d'ajouter un
PER d'imposition rapporterait CIN fois
plus que ce qu'on est en train de
demander aux étudiants qui sont loin
d'avoir les moyens d'assum not alors que
du côté des personnes qui gagnent 125000
et plus on aurait la possibilité euh de
d'assumer je veux dire ce ce partage
collectif parce que la lutte des
étudiants c'est pas lutte des étudiants
c'est la lutte de la société québécoise
vous savez dans prochaine décennies 1
péréducation au Québec tout ça faut
100000 postes ouais à pourvoir dans
prochaine décenniees 60 % nécessite
d'éducation supérieure fait qu'on a
vraiment pas les moyen de se passer
d'étudiant d'étudiants qui se
laisseraient ou qui seraient découragé
parce qu'on on va avoir aussi les frais
de scolarité